destination set it down nice and easy
for me don't I always
if by always you mean not once major
all right you have the rendezvous
coordinates far into the forest
from there we access the portal to
Raiden sky temple where there's an angry
former elder God and Devils waiting for
us
God's portals flying demons blind guys
with magic swords the world has changed
for the worse if we do not expel shinnok
from Raiden's temple he means to poison
Earth realms life force the jinn say and
we're not gonna let that happen
catchy and I appreciate the major
allowing us join you we're happy to help
kick [ __ ] off some bony ass back to the
net around
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
No
yeah getting a little ahead of yourself
aren't you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
got to get back to the chopper Sonia get
out of that was unpleasantly cold
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I liked it better when we fought on the
same side okay he we fared better than
the men Adam to the list of things
shinnok Lancer for
you
you